comme elle le fait tous les jours
tamarins une intervenante communautaire
va rencontrer des personnes âgées qui
ont besoin des domiciles je viens de la
carrière de type hot
bonjour l'affairé de votre nom vous avez
besoin d'établir cette journée là elle
rencontre monique 86 ans il son mari
laurent qui en à 88
même s'ils sont bien conscients que leur
état de santé s'est détérioré au cours
des derniers mois ce qui souhaitent le
plus au monde c'est de rester ensemble
dans leur maison et ce qu'ils veulent
c'est du soutien de missiles nos enfants
et jeunes de bobines ouais mais un
travail sur poteaux jours ici pour nous
et digne et plus et 14
on manque de coffre pour manger une fois
on peut marquer dix l'aider à faire de
même
on a plus de 12 pour elle le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
pourquoi et d'icade et améliorer la
domitienne on a de la misère à voir des
services dans l'ouest de l'île de
montréal où il habite les budgets
alloués à l'aide et demi c'est selon nos
calculs ont diminué de 6% cette année
par rapport à l'an passé ce qui se
traduit par cent mille heures de service
privé en moins cette année et tamar en
voit les effets sur le terrain
elle affirme même avoir rencontré une
dame de 85 ans qui attend depuis huit
mois de l'aide pour prendre un bain
j'étais chacun je pense je suis encore
choqué c'est important que je fais me
suivait avec le célé c'est parce que ce
n'est pas normal on ne devrait pas
attendre dans l'ensemble des
établissements santé de l'île de
montréal
toujours selon nos calculs les budgets
de l'aide à domicile ont baissé cette
année de près de 9%
une somme équivalant à 9 millions pas
étonnant donc que les effets de ces
réductions budgétaires se fassent sentir
un peu partout à montréal
même à l'autre bout de l'île dans l'est
de la ville
ce qu'on constate en tête c'est les
services de maintien à domicile qui sont
requis pour nos clients
vieillissante particulièrement la
clientèle qui vit en hlm celle qu'on
connaît le muc
ils peuvent attendre parfois de 6,1 pour
obtenir des services des bains ménages
jeanine fontaine elle a dû attendre près
d'un an avant d'obtenir de l'aide à
domicile de son celle ci il faut mettre
ces alice qui vous attendez vous
attendez si c'est pas courageuse et paf
on se plante un peu mais ça peut prendre
beaucoup de temps
je vous dis pas ce que je lui dis qu on
voit bien qu'on est dans une période
d'austérité importante
je crois que la population du québec est
très consciente de ce qui se pense des
services publics qui ne sont pas
suffisants
le ministre québécois de la santé se
défend d'avoir sabrer dans les soins
domicile nous avons augmenté d'environ
100 millions avec la réévaluation des
besoins et sur l'île de montréal pour
l'ensemble des services à domicile pour
l'ensemble c'est + 19 %
on évalue que le coût d'une place en 6 h
et celle des pour une personne âgée
varie de 42 à 71 1000 $ par année alors
qu'une personne qui restent à domicile
ne coûte que quelques milliers de
dollars au gouvernement
laurent lui atteint coup de pouce du
clsc pour l'aider à prendre un bain mais
ce que veut surtout montrer leurs seins
c'est de continuer à vivre ensemble dans
leur maison où il habite depuis 50 ans
jean-philippe il ya peut-être une
distinction importante à faire pour que
les gens comprennent bien parce que le
nice barrette le dit que les besoins
augmentent et nous parle des soins à
domicile en général vous dans ce
reportage vous parlez des de l'aide à
domicile
oui effectivement le ministre il parle
pas vraiment du budget total
et quand il nous parle donc il amalgame
à la fois l'aide à domicile et les soins
à domicile et nous alors vous l'avez dit
notre reportage ce n'était que de coller
des demies ciel ce qu'on a eu comme
document les chiffres on s'est basé sur
des documents qu'on a obtenu et qui nous
parle entre autres des prévisions
budgétaires des budgets pour les cinq
sur ce qu'on retrouve ici sur l'île de
montréal et mais ce qui est clair
céline mais vous l'avez entendu un
reportage peu importe les chiffres quand
on voit sur le terrain
ce que nous disent les gens que ce soit
dans le milieu de la santé ou encore
d'un milieu communautaire c'est qu'il y
a des besoins et que les personnes âgées
attendent vont attendre parfois une
semaine ou encore plusieurs mois
plusieurs semaines ne pourra avoir accès
à de l'aide à domicile mais est ce qu'on
peut imaginer parce qu'il ya des gens
qui doivent prendre la relève que le
gouvernement va se dégager un jour de
cette aide à domicile
oui la question elle peut se poser quand
on sait que le gouvernement veut
valoriser beaucoup les entreprises
d'économie sociale donc un secteur qu'il
veut valoriser pourquoi parce qu'il voit
entre autres une possibilité de création
d'emplois merci beaucoup j'en finis très
bon reportage bien sûr voir